absolument media hey way you got out
sales
leading team Steven Naismith is chance
the rapper the big day is finally here
we're hoping that he won't disappoint
however there has been videos online of
his shooting for him and quite frankly
it is atrocious
an alleged article said he missed 11
shots in a row and unlike his hit single
that is a problem
is he yeah uh y-you got on quite low
returning for his third NBA celebrity
game quavo makes another appearance
after dropping 27 points last year and
18 point MVP performance in 2018 he is
showing to be one of the best players on
the court he's incredible left hand
finishes and a wonderful jump shot
there goes that man one of the players
to watch for sure what about a Joe
Wilson yet aja Wilson of the Las Vegas
Asus was named WNBA Rookie Player of the
Year in Tizen 18 this past season she
drops 16.5 points per game on average
the fact that she is a professional
basketball player I expect her to be one
of the best players on the court Darius
Miles retired NBA player played for
eight seasons during his career I'm
looking for T's multifaceted roles
during this game as he was a small
forward he's also 6 9 which is really
tall Hill towel over all the other
players what about Marc Lasry Marc Lasry
is making his fifth appearance in the
NBA celebrity game I'll know his points
have taken a decline in his past couple
games his rebounds do say a consistent
probably some easy passes some easy
layups
hey cool but what you got over on a 2k
Ronnie 2k marketing director at 2k
Sports is looking to make his return to
the NBA celebrity scene although last
game showed some pretty low great layup
skills and some fragrance on defense
so hopefully this time around to keep it
a little more clean I'm looking forward
to seeing his improvements but also not
expecting too much
hey coop will give me what you got on
Taylor Bennett
Bennett is the brother of chance the
rapper and he's making his first
appearance in the NBA Celebrity game his
jump shot has not been exposed unlike
his brother or hoping for something a
little bit better there is a significant
height difference between the two he is
significantly shorter we all know
statistically speaking in basketball
that's not very good
Cooper what you get on the Roy's Hopkins
huh laroy's Hawkins was actually
recruited to play basketball in high
school sir do you know he has some
skills in his bag
but in sophomore year he did quit
playing basketball to join the speech
team so unless he's Larry Bird or Kevin
Garnett with trash talk I don't see that
doing much hey hey cool
tell me about spice Adams yeah all right
cheese yeah ah ha ha ha Anthony spice
Adams is looking to bring his team's an
excellent box out skills in the paint
well this past as an offensive end he
know he has some nice agility and
footwork so be sure to look out for that
hey tell me about this little rail guy
hey little ray Howry has said he's
played a lot and watch a lot of
basketball when he's younger
so what would be surprising is the nice
jump shot it's a nice handles I'm
expecting some smart play from him and
some smart passing that being said he is
five six so he might gets one